[Applause]
I'm not standing on a desk hey folks
this one is a patreon sponsored review
commissioned and requested I have now
rewatched because I have seen it before
Dead Poets Society this isn't a really
kind of a weird one for me to talk about
and I have a distinct feeling I'm gonna
be talking about this one a much more
academic terms than I usually do with
these kinds of reviews my feelings on I
come at it from that angle to such a
degree that I was tempted to actually
try and script this out and do it as a
full-blown like video essay but the
problem was I couldn't come up with a
conclusion that I was reaching towards
only that this seems to be the only way
that I can process and think of this
film is from a more intellectual more
academic place and the main reason for
that is I have difficulty connecting
with this movie emotionally there are a
number of reasons for that but the first
thing I want to say right off the bat is
that does not make this a bad film nor
does it even make it a film that fails
and what it sets out to do what it means
is that what it is doing doesn't really
connect to my own experience for a
number of reasons and in a variety of
ways it doesn't mean that I think it's
bad it just means it's kind of not for
me to whatever degree I was able to ever
connect with this film that was at an
earlier point in my life and watching it
now I'm probably more distant from it
than I've ever been in terms of being in
the field where it was gonna connect
with me honestly I probably needed to
see this in high school I didn't though
first time I saw it I was already in my
20s and I enjoyed it at least I remember
enjoying it but I also remember thinking
it's a little pretentious which I'm not
gonna say that's an unfair
term but is also I think a little harsh
pretension is a term used when something
acts like it has something important to
say but doesn't really and it's not that
Dead Poets Society hat doesn't have much
to say it's that what it's saying is
just kind of lost on me so where do we
go with this okay so in case you're
watching this review and don't know the
movie I think most people know well most
people my age know this movie anyway I
don't you hunger people watch this movie
at all they're not somebody I'll have to
tell me but this is a boarding-school
film it is set at a prestigious boarding
school in the 50s I think me it's it
it's not contemporary from when it was
made and it stars a quite a number of
up-and-coming young male actors of the
day and Robin Williams as their new
poetry teacher who is instructing them
to basically break molds and really
challenges the way that they have
otherwise been taught by this university
to go about their lives and how they
take in new information now that
structure is by no means unique to this
movie it's actually it's been around for
a while and it's been reused more than a
few times since then it's the the
inspiring teacher is not a new or
particularly unique story it wasn't even
new at the time this was made what this
does and I do think it's to its credit
it does really narrow in on a pretty
specific type of I I'm not sure I want
to say type of intended audience but the
experience that it is trying to evoke is
not universal this is not trying to be a
broad reaching connects with everybody's
story it is speaking to really specific
experiences which is not to say that you
needed to have been in a boarding school
seventy years ago in order to connect
with it but what it is
- is the experience of young privileged
white men and I'm hoping that people
will take my saying that as an
acknowledgement of fact and not a
condemnation that's who it's about and
that's the experience that it's speaking
towards that's not to say that other
people cannot connect to it but it's
really hammering hard on that and I
think it's part of the reason that I am
not able to connect with it because
despite growing up white male and
privilege like not badly off but let's
go with that I didn't want for a lot I I
didn't have to worry about whether or
not I was gonna get a filling meal or
anything like that so I was decently you
know in terms of my circumstances
growing up they were fine but like I
certainly also wasn't at a level where I
was going to be sent off to a
prestigious boarding school that years
people up to be able to go to Harvard
and I think part of the reason that even
though at least at the time that I was
the age of these boys in this movie I
did fit that demographic even watching
this younger didn't properly connect
with me because I didn't feel confined
by that which isn't to say that some or
many even young people young men
especially don't what it's a movie it's
about it's a movie about young men who
are have thrust upon them
heavy expectations based entirely on
what their parents did and want for them
they either their parents or their
parents generation because pretty much
nobody of 30s and younger is portrayed
particularly negatively and nobody over
40 ides well 50 definitely is portrayed
in a very good light like there's one
teacher who kind of
straddles the border who kind of bonds a
little bit with Keating Robin Williams
is character but we don't also see a lot
of that I'll kind of come back to that
and a little bit in a way but it is very
much geared towards how young men are
confined by the structures placed on
them by the generation that built what
they now live it and it is a story that
only works if you come at it with a
certain understanding of privilege
because privilege while yeah
if you if you have it it's kind of hard
to knock but it is confining in its own
way now it's a difficult thing to talk
about because anytime you start to go oh
woe is the well-off white male on a
college track Oh boohoo
but the simple truth is human experience
no matter who you are there is something
that makes your existence more difficult
for you not necessarily that that
experience would be difficult for
anybody else other people are probably
gonna envy what you've got in most
circumstances but that doesn't mean that
for you the life that you're living is
easy and wonderful it just means that
the hardships you endure are not are not
ones of poverty or lack of opportunity
or things of that nature but there are
still hardships emotional and
psychological ones if not physical and
financial ones and that is what this is
speaking to and I think for what it is
aiming to do for the most part it does
it well the performances are very
committed you definitely get the
impression from Williams all through the
younger cast everybody is really into
what they are doing and that helps
unique if you're gonna do this you need
to do it with sincerity because that is
the one place where you will completely
fall on your face if it doesn't feel
like you mean what you're saying if
you're gonna do a story like this I do
feel that there are a number of
other things about it that hold me at a
distance and these are more issues for
me watching it now as an adult unless so
what I would have seen it initially so
I've talked before about the issues I
have with the aggrandize ation of well
I've said before the author but I would
say writers creators artists in general
and I said that is someone who with
aspirations to be an artist of some form
who most of my creative heroes are
artists but collectively creators
artists writers poets we pat ourselves
on the back oh and this movie does that
oh and I say that is somebody who you
know art has always been incredibly
meaningful meaningful to me and as far
as channels go it's why I talk about
whether you consider things like Doctor
Who art or not it is an artistic piece
of work you know this is this is what I
do with my time but there's just
something about alright here's the thing
art is incredibly important and no one
should ever be deprived or miss out on
the opportunity to experience and have
art in their lives however what it feels
like films such as Dead Poets Society is
doing if not explicitly certainly
implicitly saying that it is art alone
that gives life meaning it is artistic
expression alone that gives you
fulfilling us and I just don't like the
self-importance of that if nothing else
and again my life without art would be
empty in a lot of ways I would be
missing a lot of things that matter to
me but the way like say for instance
when the teaching and and narrative Lee
there's a reason to do this we have a
montage of all these other classes and
it's very dry it is very academic there
Lattin by rote where they just have to
repeat the conjugations over and over
and over and over again it's it is
soulless and that is done to narrative
lis contrast the teaching method that is
standard at the school with that of
Keating so it serves a narrative purpose
but the implicit message behind that
intended or not and I'm not gonna argue
as to whether or not it is but I think
it's there regardless is that only art
gets to be different only art gets to
ignite passion which is not true if you
are an artistic person art is what will
ignite your passion but there are people
who are passionate about science about
mathematics about coding you know there
is plenty of places to find passion in
your life but because art is created by
artists pretty much every piece of art
every piece of entertainment is going to
lean very heavily on how much art gives
you passion because that's what gave the
people who created this piece of art
passion and it becomes a little bit of a
little bit of a circle jerk and this is
not the most egregious example I've ever
seen of that but it does fall into that
spiral a bit and also the tail end I
feel goes off the rails for a couple of
reasons before I get to kind of the
elephant in the room when it comes to
talking about this movie the first is
that remember how I mentioned that
Keating has this other teacher who he
seems to develop some kind of friendship
with who's slightly older than him but
not as old as most of the other teachers
seem to be or at least not as stuffy
that's only implied because this movie
isn't really about Keating it isn't even
really about his method of trying to
teach it is about these young boys
trying to find their own voices and the
ways in which Keating yes ignites them
down that path but it's not really about
him he's a catalyst but it's not his
story
which makes it very strange to me that
the ending decides to completely hang
itself on the tragedy of Keating losing
his job but the story hasn't been about
him and I understand that it's still
framed through the eyes of the boys who
see this as a loss but it really does
feel like the film in its last 20
minutes has decided that it's going to
be much more about the teacher as a
person than about what he instilled in
them or at least that's the vibe I got
people might disagree with me on that
and I may have overstated it it doesn't
completely lose the threat of where it
was going but it's a tip that I don't
think serves what the movie had been up
to that point which then does bring us
to the elephant in the room which is the
character of Niel who upon being
instructed by his father that because he
went he participated in a play against
his father's wishes that he will be sent
off to a military academy and then
forced to go to medical school and his
response to that is to commit suicide my
big problem with this entire plot point
is that for a film that is very heavy on
its thematics on its philosophical
inclinations I don't know what it's
trying to say with this plot term is it
trying to be like this is the extreme
result of far too much oppression of
youth by older people because that point
had been made earlier I don't think it
helps it to hammer at this home this
hard and also if that's what it's trying
to do it's somewhat flawed as a as an
idea for that to even be but saying
because honestly this is an absurd
reaction
like I I get that the kids upset I'm not
even gonna say I don't buy that the kid
kills himself i buy it but when looking
at it again maybe if you adult eyes I
can't look at this and help but come
away with part of the problem here is he
had poured so much of his sense of self
into these artistic leanings that when
they were taken away he had nothing that
he felt mattered and again that's not
necessarily a fault of writing or fault
of characterization because especially
when you're young you get over indulgent
of your passions like I think that's
fair enough to say which again is why I
don't say I don't buy but he does it
because it's not a rational decision
it's an emotional decision duh but at
the same time it muddies any possible
message because I can't help but feel
that his very haphazardly constructed
sense of self is at least partially to
blame for this and you can't lay it all
on the father the school system whatever
you want to blame or whatever the film
seems to want you to blame again it's
nothing it's awful and of itself but it
feels like in the entire last act of the
film it starts to lose how these events
and how these turns of character feed
into the lessons the philosophy of the
film now there are some points in which
the espoused philosophy of carpe diem
seize the day does get challenged in
good credible ways such as by actually
Keating himself when one of his students
makes a big show of things in in the
public hall and nearly gets expelled
Keating rightfully calls him out like
that wasn't daring that was stupid you
know but the the problem is is that in
some ways it does
illustrate the failings of what keating
is doing because he has this philosophy
and he's able to balance it because he
has enough life experience to know when
it's better to back off and these boys
don't and I'm not going to agree with
the with the other teachers who are like
espousing this to young men is dangerous
like no they should know this but
because they have not been raised to
understand this and instead they're
having it dumped on them now in their
teens when they are hormonal II
emotionally just a massive ball of a
very volatile energy yeah that's a
little reckless because you know the the
system the school system this society
has been capping that energy basically
shaking up a soda bottle the whole time
and keating just say oh well let's just
well no you're gonna find a wanting to
find a way to release that a little bit
more gradually because it's been clamped
down so long and again I don't I just
feel like it's one of those cases where
there wasn't full thought put into the
implications of some of the things that
happen particularly in the latter half
including some things that have not even
necessarily gonna knock it for at the
time but certainly watching now are
incredibly cringy there's the character
of Knox who falls in love with a girl
who he literally saw once and then goes
to a party and she's asleep and they're
her head is kind of near his lap and he
strokes her hair and kisses her forehead
and as it was building up to that I was
sitting there going oh god no no no no
okay I mean consent much she can't she's
not conscious and the only consequence
he gets for that is to get roughed up by
her boyfriend because she belongs to
somebody else and then later going to
her school humiliating her by reading
this poem in front of all of her
classmates which she then goes to
confront him and tries to call him out
on but he just pleads and begs until she
gives him much
and oh my god that made me sick to my
freaking stomach and especially when he
says look just come with me to watch
this play and if you don't like me at
the end of that I'll leave you alone she
doesn't owe you anything but he felt he
was entitled to his one shot he's not
that one while it made me angry I'm
gonna spend less time talking about
because I think about the time in which
it was made and the fact that that
entire thing was framed very much as oh
what a daring young boy taking a shot it
was typical of the time as much as that
annoys me to have to acknowledge but it
is at the same time framed very much
through the lens of these boys so the
fact that he doesn't know her but feels
he falls in love with her and that it
frames women very loosely as objects of
desire when it acknowledges women at all
that's that's applicable to boys at that
age especially if in their day-to-day
lives they don't counter women or girls
their age so again it's I mean that
specific moment aside it's not that it's
doing a bad job of what it's trying to
do is just that what it's trying to do
doesn't speak to me and the things that
feel like maybe they should speak to me
don't quite land they're slightly
off-center I think it's a pretty
well-made film and I definitely get why
some people really connect with it I do
it makes total sense to me but it just
doesn't connect with me like that
doesn't make it a bad movie doesn't make
it a stupid movie doesn't mean that
you're wrong to like or love it
it just means that I don't but that's my
thoughts on Dead Poets Society it's a
noble try it's not for me what are your
thoughts on this movie I am really
afraid I'm gonna take some people
with this I don't know something my gut
tells me that but whatever your thoughts
are drop something down the comments
let's talk about it usual stuff like
subscribe hit the bell I guess it helps
I share this around if you like I have a
patreon that was how I was commissioned
to review this particular piece of work
and check all that out or don't end of
the day folks
you're the council I'm just running the
meetings and until next time carpe diem
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]